[Music]
what's controversial drug comments that
Woody Harrelson make during his recent
Saturday night's live appearance and how
are other celebrities and social media
reacting keep watching to find out this
weekend Zombieland the Natural Born
Killer star Woody Harrelson returned to
host Saturday Night Live for the fifth
time this made him officially part of
the illustrious five-timers Club joining
other established members like Tom Hanks
Steve Martin and Paul Rudd however this
was not the most momentous aspect of
this Saturday's show instead debating
controversies spiked across social media
about comments the actor made during his
seven minute monologue if you know about
Harrelson's private life you know that
he is no saint nor does he claim to be
over the last decade Harrelson has been
quite outspoken about certain points in
his life including those times when he
got into the most trouble this is
evident in interviews including one from
2017 with The Hollywood Reporter in
which Harrelson sounds quite candid and
self-aware about his past mistakes at
the end of the interview he admits that
he's still a rebel the heart who enjoys
living on the edge Harrelson said
I got the most amazing wife I could
imagine but did marriage calm me down I
don't think anything will ever calm me
down taking the SNL stage once again
Harrelson was faithful to himself and
used his daring sense of humor and
unreserved bluntness in a monologue that
caught many off guard that being said a
few of the statements made by Harold's
son have sent the internet into an
uproar bringing to the surface of
polarizing incendiary debate that the
pandemic sparked during his monologue
Harrelson made no attempts to hide his
pass with alcohol or the fact that he
still has a seemingly functional
relationship with the devil's lettuce
however it may be surprising to some
that these were not the drugs mentioned
in the actor's monologue that caused the
impassioned online clamor laws of the
fact that Harrelson rather hilariously
through his poor manager Jeremy under
the bus for breaking the law by claiming
he and not the actor transported weed
from California to New York what's
instigated the online fuhrer was
Harrelson's use of a metaphor to make an
implicit critique of covered measures
and denounce the big pharmaceut critical
companies behind the vaccines Allison
talked about smoking a joint and sitting
under a tree in Central Park to read
this probably fictional film script
Harrelson said so the movie goes like
this the biggest drug cartels in the
world get together and buy up all the
media and all the politicians and force
all the people in the world to stay
locked in their homes and people could
only come out if they take the cartel's
drugs and keep taking them over and over
I threw the script away I mean who was
going to believe that crazy idea and
surprisingly there are two opposing
views on the implications of Harrelson's
unbelievable script anecdote One
commands and agrees with the actor the
other attacks and discredits him Nick
Brennan who has worked for NBC in the
past had one of the most retweeted
responses on Twitter what on Earth was
this anti-vaxx nonsense MMA fighter Jade
Shields replied it's called Truth two
hours after his anti-vaxx nonsense post
Brennan posted a screenshot of Twitter
CEO Elon musk's favorable response to
the SNL Monologue captioning it and here
it all makes sense on reddit's the
responses were equally polarized one
user replied odd just watch the entire
monologue and thought it was well done
it never came off as an anti-vaxx rent
on a different board another user
criticized both this monologue and
another recent one by comedian Dave
Chappelle
and they just had Dave Chappelle giving
an anti-semitic monologue a few months
ago gross so don't take medical advice
from actors especially actors who admit
they spend most of their time Stoned on
YouTube the majority of the top comments
seem to be in Harrison's Corner one
YouTube user wrote that's what you call
being natural on the stage then he
proves he's more high-minded than all
the rest at the end and leaves them flat
love it another comments have pointed
out the live studio reactions or lack
thereof stating love the audience
silence at the cartel joke one user went
as far as splitting in words what many
viewers must have thought when watching
the monologue writing and just like that
he was never seen again in Hollywood or
on SNL whether you agree or disagree
whether you find it Brave or unhinged it
is undeniable that Harrelson took a risk
with this controversial joke
[Music]